very many of us suffer from a peculiar
sounding problem an inability properly
to inhabit the stretch of time we call
the present maybe we're on a beautiful
beach on a sunny day the skies azure and
the palm trees slender and implausibly
delicate but most of us isn't actually
here at all it's somewhere at work or in
imaginary discussion with a rival or
plotting a new enterprise or maybe we're
at the birthday of a child
its enormous ly significant for her and
we love her dearly but we are elsewhere
our body is rooted in the now but our
minds are skipping two points in both
the future and the past what is it that
makes the present especially the nicer
moments of the present so difficult to
experience properly and why
conversely can so many events feel
easier to enjoy appreciate and perceive
when they're firmly over one benefit of
the past is that it is a dramatically
foreshortened edited version of the
present even the best days of our lives
contain a range of dull or uncomfortable
moments but in memory like skilled
editors of hours of raw and often
uninspired footage we can lock on to the
most consequential moments and therefore
construct sequences that feel a great
deal more meaningful and interesting
than the settings that generated them
hours of mediocrity can be reduced to
five or six perfect images and nostalgia
is the present enhanced by an editing
machine much of what ruins the present
is sheer anxiety the present always
contains an enormous number of
possibilities some hugely gruesome which
we're constantly aware of anything could
theoretically happen an earthquake and
aneurysm of rejection which gives rise
to a nonspecific anxiety that trails
around us most of the time the simple
dread at the unknown Ness
of what is to come but then of course
only a very limited range of awful
things do ever come to pass and we
forget the anxiety at once rather shift
to the new present so when we remember
an event what we leave out of it is how
much of that event we actually spent
anticipating an appalling future that
never came our bodies further
contributes to our distraction from the
present they have their own moods and
itineraries they might feel tired and
timid at just the moment when the
landscape around us would demand
grandeur and confidence but these
dissonant moods also get edited out of
memory we'll remember the view over the
ocean far longer than the slight
queasiness which turned us in on
ourselves at the time our minds our
cavernous chaotic places so much courses
through them that has little to do with
what is right in front of our eyes we
can end up seeming ungrateful to where
we are someone is telling us an
important story and not from any evil
motive
just from the difficulty of having to
manage the entity called AI we digest
some regret or rather instead we're at a
beautiful location but we can barely
take in the vegetation and the
extraordinary views so fixated are we on
an event that will only occur in six
months time we need to be prepared for
the weird way in which we align with the
world and not berate ourselves unduly
for our difficulties at doing justice to
where our bodies and minds happen to be
we should be ready for this disloyalty
in other people too at moments when they
look strangely worried at a party we've
laid on or don't seem to be listening to
a story we're telling them they too may
just be experiencing some of the major
difficulties of being in the present
like us they'll probably enjoy our
encounter with us so much more when the
present a safely given way to memory
you